the first time I heard about you
actually because uh I don't normally
like play fortnite so I'm not really
like in that scene uh yeah I mean I
don't play it as much of that
uh but yeah it was was actually was
actually from a Mr Beast video it was
the private uh the private jet video
that uh uh yeah the hand on the private
jet yeah okay so awful experience
exposing Mr Beast right now everything
he fakes it all fakes all these videos
he he like hit us with bats every now
and then wouldn't let us go to the
bathroom
yeah yeah so I I think the concept of
the video was like lost to take the hand
off the jet yeah did you
okay Mike fourth
was there for 20 hours thank you very
much I left two hours before the end so
so like filming on a Mr Beast video that
in turns where I
I've known him for a few years right
um but
had never been I guess like I
technically was in a video but never
been in a video before
and I think it made me appreciate him a
lot more because I've been in videos
with some people who
they'll like blur the edges a little bit
they'll like force things to happen if
it needs to happen for the video right
he is when it comes to filming the most
authentic individual because like
he wants it to happen like for real like
there's no like there was a whole thing
where he'd booked out like other
airports with like other activities that
were supposed to fly to in the Jet right
but because enough people didn't get
eliminated in time for us to get like
the clearance to go fly we needed to get
down to like six people seven people or
something
um and we didn't like people didn't drop
off fast enough we just had to scrap all
that
oh my like that he just like invested in
all this but he never I respected a lot
because he never forced people to get
eliminated yeah he made it difficult but
he was never like one of you guys got to
go like he never games that he was like
if you can withstand this punishment
we'll sit here like we're not he didn't
like rig it so that we would have to go
here or you know we'd have to get to
this number by this time so the video is
done by this time because we've got to
be done he made sure he like booked out
everything for as long as he needed to
like with tons of room
um he made sure like there's no bathroom
breaks like you're going with your hand
on the plane right
um we're eating with our hand on the
plane oh yeah he put like this little
tent around us oh yeah yeah yeah you had
to smell the urine of the people next to
you oh my god disgust did anyone need to
[__] no one likely needed to oh god um I
guess luckily enough there was no women
on the shoot in that regard because like
I would feel so bad for them that would
be like a cancel Mr Beast moment that
would be mistreating him
um but yeah he's just so authentic and
real when it comes to that and that's
why he has so many people and like so
many stuff and like he has all these
contingency plans for every sort of
outcome because he wants it to be
authentic yeah and I was like he didn't
even blur any lines he was like
this your hand is on the jet if you keep
your hand on the jet you win the jet
that's it right there's no [__] was
it torturous
awful awful and because everyone else
was a psychopath like we're all just
standing there and you just had to keep
you can't sit down anymore you can't
rescue any surface that was like resting
your hands slightly can't do it you have
to be held up like on top of the gym
and then he taped us together to another
competitor and that's what did me and I
was I just couldn't handle the tape
anymore I had a bloke next to me he was
like leaning on me I was landing on him
and then yeah everyone else had their
tape removed because certain people got
eliminated so they'll just had no tape
anymore and I was like just flip the
coin see if I can get rid of the tape
yeah how much did he tell you prior to
like the shooting because it was like
how did he picture just like hey I'm
doing this video with a problem doing
this video hands going on a jet do you
want to be in it it's not very
complicated although we went to go
now that was we went to go film it and
then I think it got
canceled at the move the date right so
we've got we got all the shooting
location had to turn around that was fun
but that's because like everything
wasn't ready you didn't want it to be
yeah yeah yeah [__] so then we have
to film it the day after the Cyberman
charity match so everyone was like
exhausted I didn't sleep really before
at all
um there's a lot of eye ligma in that
video I was looking very fried I do not
do drugs it is purely from a medical
condition
um so yeah I mean he picked the worst
day that's why like half the sidemen
weren't in it because
yeah if I can't be asked that was that
supposed to be more originally ah yeah
no I think it was meant to be like I
don't know if I'm leaking [__] but
nothing matters I don't think but yeah
uh yeah no I think originally it was
meant to be like all the sidemen yeah
yeah just except I think Vic was the
only one were you in the side of man
charity match yes I was but you're easy
to miss me because [__] did nothing
I'm not an athletic individual so if you
guys don't know I tried my absolutely
is just basically they just do football
game rent out a stadium it's actually
pretty [__] cool yeah one of the best
moments it's very British and they play
football walking on a pitch in front of
like it was like 30 000 people or
something it's insane it's such a cool
concert I love sport but I'm obviously
not athletic so I got to like role play
for like a day which position did you
play ah kind of I think I was midfield
for most of it played uh yeah I think I
was left back at one point against speed
oh my God he was doing some weird things
saying some weird [__]
nice guy though actually really nice
surprise me you're any good at Freddy no
no I'll just run I run like a penguin
right I was just like running like such
a goofy dumbass like the whole time
watching the Clips back later I'm like I
did not need to see that you know have
you ever considered how you run you've
probably never thought about it have you
you well no you because you'd never
[__] see it you just don't think
about it until you see it especially
when you're in past quality yeah you see
broadcast quality of you trying to
Sprint after a football
[__] it it's eye-opening
shocked so you never run again I don't
think I'm running again yeah just
wearing it off I go for jogs and stuff
and I'm like thinking everyone walking
past me you've seen they're seeing that
they're seeing me running like a penguin
or I've got a [__] in my pants I'm
trying to squeeze my cheeks oh boy as a
kid though I I play baseball
that's why everyone's like we're gonna
sucked at baseball oh gosh I didn't I
don't have my brother's genetics
damn did you only play baseball or like
any other sports as well
um mostly baseball I did a little like
School Sport and stuff yeah because
what's nice in a rugby what's normally
in Australia for like the curriculum
because in like in in in England
obviously you have like 30 uh cricket as
well yes as well I think for us it's
like Cricket like footy like rugby yeah
that's pretty much it pretty much it
that's all I like all I did for PE was
like yeah pretty much just Cricket yeah
yeah not not keeping your hand on the
the jet no no nothing prepared me for
them why didn't the school prepare me
for the real [__] man I think if I if I
just slept the night before
or if I just could if I won that coin
flip to get a tape off I reckon I want